Grandma got indefinitely detained now
trying to come visit Christmas eve.
You could claim she had a right to counsel
but some folks in the Congress disagree.
She was flying home to our house
but she got stopped by TSA.
Thought she might be Abdulmutallab
when they had a look at grandma's old x-ray.
Her hair had recently been colored
she paid cash for her Christmas gifts.
Two things apparently the Congress
has determined might make you a terrorist.
Grandma got indefinitely detained now
trying to come visit Christmas eve.
They took her rights in order to protect her rights,
the most genious plan ever in history.
But see we need to have these powers
to help protect this free country.
But if it takes these steps to do so
what is it exactly we are protecting?
Now she's an enemy combatant
as if that makes any sense.
The only thing that she's combating
is her unpredictable incontinence.
Grandma got indefinitely detained now
trying to come visit Christmas eve.
You could claim there's no right to due process
but check the 5th Amendment and you'll see.
Grandma got indefinitely detained now
never made it home on Christmas day.
She always wanted to live in Miami
at least she's just 90 miles away.
Merry Christmas.